name we have no viewers yet no John go
back this is very behind-the-scenes
thing before anyone chimes in
we just need at least five faces on here
five and then we can get going right now
we have one person here one okay we are
doing get Steve from high school is here
thank you oh we got people oh man look
at look at the people showing up we're
gonna talk about Little Mermaid in just
a minute this is the you know a lot of
movie news has been dropping lately and
will cover something movie news sure but
this is the one that we most need to
talk about first off I must confirm can
everyone in the chat hear me okay I need
confirmation confirmation I need two
people to say yes you look like
markiplier not gonna lie though I've
heard that one too many times and I like
to think I'm like Marco pliers
you know if Superman had a twin brother
who didn't have powers that would be me
I am like that version of markiplier
Anthony Daley says I am angry my
favorite movie they better do good
here's to dough well since we have 200
people in this live stream you know what
yeah I'm angry too man dammit god dammit
why the hell would they do this with the
casting don't they know that
historically speaking mermaids are all
white yeah it's just factual oh man
they're all like Norwegian they got that
red hair pale complexion like don't be
this is so racist if you look Halle
Berry Halle Bailey when I read the
headline at first Olly Barry Holly Bell
Valley has been cast hullabaloo to play
Ariel and I am I am upset because my my
fictionalized non-human character his
being portrayed not by a white redhead
which just is historically inaccurate
John it's historically inaccurate it's
okay I mean Shane Woodley was busy
where's the anger here worse John you're
white a c-cup
Oh defend your people feel so insulted
that that all of the movie character I
have no longer get to claim every
prominent lead character as part of my
team anymore and this is really
upsetting to me now I have a few less
team members and I don't know what
honestly I'm gonna do with myself I feel
like my culture is being trampled on
even though my culture is just derived
from a lot of other places but you know
I think this is a slap in the face of
all of us Disney shills I don't know
what they're doing and I refuse to
accept any more of their review checks
at least for this movie what's next is
Sebastian gonna be played by a Japanese
crab is Mulan gonna be white they'll get
a real crab to play Sebastian that's
that's what's gonna happen a real
flounder look who is she
all right look let me tell you who she
is it is not Halle Berry is a
african-american actress slash very
talented singer and that's about as far
as I know she has kind of an
otherworldly I can almost see her in a
Tim Burton movie the way her face and
eyes like her face shape and the size of
her eyes gosh but I can see how she got
that kind of mermaid esque look that
sort of yet otherworldly look hey hey no
one's calling you racist for how you
feel buddy this is this is not right our
satirical sarcasm and yeah I don't know
I don't think anybody's I don't know I
gotta hear what people are controversy
about if it's just I didn't expect her
to be black I'm like that's a bit not a
drag people are the first thing I heard
was the controversy because she's not
she's not Caucasian redhead really okay
yes and I'm gonna break it I'm gonna
break it down to you guys okay I don't
think it matters it doesn't matter
mermaids aren't real yeah yeah exactly
your your cartoon is still gonna be
there nothing about the character
necessitates her being white or redhead
I I get that it's a it's an iconic look
but there's nothing really specific
about the character of why she's white
and a redhead you know and someone in
the comments even said that she might
actually that she was blonde in that and
in the book and as a matter of fact the
Little Mermaid animated movie is very
inaccurate to the piece oh man they're
just screwing over everything I'm mad at
the movie that original Disney animated
for screwing it up there Disney has a
trade of taking very dark and often very
cautionary tales and and making them
very cheerful and I don't know yes
different look brianna hanover thank you
for the super chat she said they should
have cast a real mermaid damn it I'm
right there with you buddy I'm right
there with you we should have got in a
real mermaid just leave the original
alone look Lynnae they're not gonna
leave any originals alone i say more
remakes and more remakes as a matter of
fact if we want to even the playing
field guys we got a like adapt
characters from the Disney animated
movies and put white people in those
roles just make everyone happy okay
let's do a white version of The Wiz and
just settle the scale The Princess and
the Frog needs to be played by Persian
people just saying that's all I'm saying
all right I thought of a messed up joke
and I debated whether or not I should I
should say the joke no I don't think you
should but I want to host the Oscars in
15 years and I just don't want it to
bite me then just give up comedy no I'm
just scared of comedy because there's no
no room for edge anymore
there's no room for really doing a whiz
at your college
review is that is that I love the review
comments okay am I actually interested
in this movie yes if they make mulan
mexican that's not the same thing though
because mulan actually has to do with
the cultural heritage of china whereas
at least in my limited knowledge of the
Little Mermaid I don't think it's making
a direct comment on like Danish living
and as somebody else pointed out there
are black Danish people Wow so
fascinating fact well no cuz like when I
remember when people were like oh not my
black spider-man when that whole like
Donald Glover should play him thing came
around and and that whole debate opened
up the idea that some characters
necessitate a certain race or look and
some don't
look I'm just mad at what Disney's doing
alright are you i watch the Latin and
they they just like it's made it all
about jasmine that whole time alright
there was no Aladdin in the movie now I
can't go back and watch the original
animated movie because there's a
live-action version that has redefined
the whole thing for everyone know it's
the official they said the old ones no
longer Canon and it's not it's not valid
you know how well guys I just wanted to
hop on there to just to tell this all on
to you guys it's America's birthday
tomorrow do you think she's gonna sing
here's the joke I want to be worth it
why people are I mean I feel like what's
growing out of our there's a place for
this joke I just don't know where is the
most appropriate place there's no place
appropriate for it okay look guys I'm
gonna repeat this once again mermaids
are real it's a character okay and I
feel like if you already got your enemy
in a movie if you're gonna sincerely
speaking if you're gonna do this version
all I care about is just the damn good
performance that's it I didn't see the
trailer at least I have heard rumors at
Harry's
Isles is gonna be Prince Eric though oh
that would be yeah that makes a lot of
very conventional sense yes I feel like
very if you're upset that Ariel doesn't
look exactly as you imagined well you'll
probably get a prettier kudasai Philip
or whichever want to use I don't I don't
listen to any one direction but I
[ __ ] love Harry Styles it's so weird
like I love watching him in interviews I
hear he's casting something now I get
excited whenever he does like comedy
bits I'm always like yay but i I've only
heard like one single one direction so
well that's because the song is named it
yeah I've heard no I've heard it's Harry
Styles one of his songs but you know
yeah so but I haven't actually I've
heard some of his solo ever more of a
soul Me's than I have heard any in one
direction but I I'd be pretty excited
for Harry Styles to be in it today via
Dunkirk
what's up Amy O'Neil I know that a
hatred for this is really in the
minority I would
get it look we're just trying to
capitalize on all the controversy man
you know what you clicked on here the
visual look of a character can be
important but I would argue that with a
character like Ariel I mean you still
have the tail you still have like the
clamshell bra like it's not only that
she has white skin and red hair I don't
know I get in this argument I do get
this sort of well there's an iconic
depiction but it is also not the origin
of this story exactly so I don't know I
I don't think it's necessarily fair I
think it's fair to say hey I'm really
attached to that original depiction it's
gonna take me some getting used to and
maybe you're not open to that and that's
whatever but yeah I don't think it's
really a choice you can take direct
issue with you know there they said that
Melissa McCarthy might actually play
Ursula okay I hope that she gets to be
like full-on sinister and they don't do
you think I'm a really a comedy
I would hope haha hey would hope what
the future we don't need Will Smith
everyone's like what's the controversy
and then if you just scroll through some
comments you'll see what the controversy
is no don't worry if you're there's a
reason there's a question mark in the
title of his life this live stream is
BYOC bring your own controversy mr. Tran
I first heard about like the people
being mad about this I was like oh god
hey Jordan Gordon your name rhymes here
Pirates of the Caribbean at World's End
was a great representation of the
mermaid possibilities they could pursue
and I think you mean on Stranger Tides
let me correct you okay
cuz I'm the smartest one in the room
don't ever apologize to be the smartest
one in the room No
no it's par for where the Rob Marshall
ironically who was directing this is the
one who heard this live stream yeah it's
written his life screams Rob Marshall
he's the one who directed that yeah I
didn't think you did a good job with the
mermaids as a matter of fact that might
be the reason why he's been tapped to do
this and yeah boy made those mermaids
and there's one of them at the cinema
makeup school Oh Jill Harlow oh they're
beautiful in person like not that they
all got used you the models but you know
the actual practical ones are gorgeous
all right guys well since we're here
we're done
all right we've said it we beat the we
beat the horse to death here shot him in
the face did the whole thing we've said
enough about it before we log off what
other questions do you guys have ask me
any that's whatever let's let's just get
this live stream going there's other
movie news that's happening right now if
you're chiming in late just for Y in the
video and go back to the thoughts on
everything we have going on what other
movie news is going on to mr. mosz Luth
of the Lear just just did a super chat
of $0.99 you cheap bastard why not make
that $1 and make us happy
thanks to differentiate it why do we
never react to the Umbrella Academy
trailer I don't know I don't know why we
didn't maybe because we're a two-man
crew and there's only so much we can
handle at once
spoiler review for spider-man should
most likely be coming out tomorrow okay
I would say don't spoil anything in the
live stream but we know that at least a
couple of you guys will be jerks about
it cuz that's just the way it works
Doody and Willie's 15 minutes been
watching since he was 11 thanks bud it
seems like some people actually don't
know about this casting we are relying
the video line the video guys rewind the
video
Olivia asks what do I think about the
Jews well I think when they adapt the
Great Mouse Detective they should make
the integration in there that's a very
specific thought and well yeah I mean
when you get the live-action version
that's what you got to do do you this
good old gamer guys really opting
movie fights right now I'm really
rooting for you I could - no you could
take dance belt oh no no no no no I
literally can type lob viously not to
use you gotta get back again hey Jean
hairstyle tips well John's is grow your
hair mine it is work with the weather
all right I rarely have my hair all
curly doubt these days you know what I
mean did we watch them which was what
are we talking about
hey John will you react to that cardi B
video oh do mister because I was just
totally kidding but at the same time I'm
glad I was able to guilt-trip you into
giving us now a total of three dollars
thank you that is harder mine it is so
appreciated I find it funny and I
simultaneously feel bad about it so
thanks - preciate no longer make fun of
people are we excited for stranger
things I I'm cautiously excited only
because I'm slightly stressed about the
fact that we're gonna try to cover it
for YouTube while also keeping all the
regular videos on YouTube and patreon
going so it just sounds like a very
daunting task because I know that as
each day goes by less interest will go
because it's a show that drops all of it
and people binge watch it yes and we
just won't be able to
we just can't binge watch the whole
thing in one day it won't be possible
oh so yeah it's gonna be a little bit
tough Johnny what a mister Katie asked a
mr. Katie asked are you team me go sir
team boneth oh oh boy I'm
under-qualified answer this question I
guess Bone Thugs seems like they may be
in the long term of things I would
imagine that bone thugs-n-harmony would
probably have a more
indelible impact over time and a more
innovative sound I feel like from what I
know about me goes who was the name of
their their big breakout record whenever
they followed that up with the part two
to that record I haven't heard very many
great things about and I've heard that
they're kind of stagnating in their
outputs though I guess from what I know
I would go team Bone Thugs cardi B is in
the can to our friend who asked that
it's come into patreon ASAP also shouts
out to puck out road movie in the chat
go go watch the trailer you guys go go
check out the most haunted road in
America because I'm buds with thoughts
on the look of the animals talking in
Lion King that it's gonna look freakin
weird but I will probably be really
charmed by it at the same time
cautiously optimistic strange to see
something looks so real and then their
mouths moving that makes you go wait
it's fake you know somebody asked I do
like classic filmmakers although I'm not
an expert enough to call myself like a
huge fan so to speak but yeah there's a
lot of great old classics and great
classic directors and a couple of my
favorite films are by them what do you
mean lines don't talk great question and
so John where do you what are you typing
to the chat right now I'm just
recommending my buddy's movie to the
chat because he's here okay wait which
one Matt yeah hey Matt I would like to
take acting classes from you
in exchange I will let you pay me $250
to attend yeah thank you Matt thank you
free for the guys listen we're gonna log
off here in a minute we only wanted to
chime in really fast I appreciate
everyone for just hopping onto our
unannounced spontaneous livestream but
we okay what do we think about Sons of
Anarchy
I feel pressure to answer it's nobody
that's a super
never a lot you think about suns of it I
wasn't trying to do some call to action
here what do we think about Sons of
Anarchy I hear it's a great show John
needs to start it I put all the pressure
on him if I haven't done something I
just redirect blame so John why haven't
you started anarchy is literally my
go-to show for when I imagine that
there's just too much TV and I know I
won't get to stuff Sons of Anarchy is
the first show that comes to mind where
I'm like I've heard it's great I
probably will never see it yes but hey
maybe I will and maybe I will eat those
words that's true it's true Della's says
right ray you look look at that cartoon
thumbnail of yours man he looked awesome
that was a guy dude I don't care I
thought della was a girl for a couple
years Adela and is a funky homosapien no
matter which we should lifes you know
they say leave the people wanting more I
think we should live stream until we're
down to zero we should leave it strong
it we shouldn't we get done at 10 people
that's how we should do it you know like
Tarantino was talking about how he
thinks he might do one more film it's
like the Michael Jordan of filmmaking
right he's like but I might retire after
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood he's not
gonna retire he's just gonna keep going
he's gonna keep going and guys I'm
really quick dude if he can't super
chill word I'm just making jokes it's
late if I can work about it we will stay
if will send more but but ya know at the
same time like no don't don't if you I
don't want anyone to feel pressured like
I appreciate everyone does that I heard
Andy mushiya he might be directing the
flash now and then he's gonna quit that
I heard Mike Flanagan my directed now
too so there's just a whole lot more to
look forward to interesting I would be
curious to see Flanagan only for the
fact that it wouldn't be horror I wonder
for the people who chime in on this live
stream to go wait who's playing Arielle
if they're gonna just wait for us to
answer that before they just go look at
to do one little Google search to go
who's playing are you a very talented
person I'm assuming I
not familiar with her work but I'm sure
she's gonna I mean they they've went to
town on trying to find the right person
in cast here so you know wait mr. Miggs
is particular you mean wait who's
Geordie smell I thought you majority
Nelson from the Green Bay Packers never
mind I'll find anybody that's really
kind of you yeah so guys what what takes
what makes livestreams the most engaging
look what can we do to better our
livestream
this is a another conversation we're
Markinson I just had a thought
you know I just want to know what what
would be the best way to do a we did a
reaction this I did a reaction of spies
in the skies trailer answering questions
okay all right all right here we go
okay answer questions shadows have asked
it is anybody have to have a still
camera but I like to have the freedom
you know I feel like just makes it more
real I wanted to do a live stream but
only as a series of still photographs
keep with the jokes I love your sense of
humor
how did Captain Hook die I mean wiped
his ass with the wrong hand I think I'm
gonna update that joke - he wiped his
penis with the wrong hey people you know
nobody has asked this question and I
honestly wonder if anybody is excited
about Game of Thrones prequels it said
97 likes I thought it said only 97
viewers really lost their data here
playing Eric I talked about a rewind the
video I'm telling you it's gonna be it's
Harry Styles Greg will you be down to
play Jon Snow and Game of Thrones remake
oh yeah man - won't it there we go hey
Jon you got a specific question for you
they said in order for us to make live
streams more interesting we got to
answer questions Jeremy 2920 asks since
you watched haunting of Hill House do
you like the doctor sleep looks similar
I mean kind of I think Mike Flanagan
just has like us I feel like his style
is just being really really good at
horror stuff so in his hands I'm excited
although I definitely want it to be
distinct from Hill House and I think if
he
goes full-on kuba with it it should be
okay okay are you excited about Game of
Thrones prequels Greg am i excited yes I
I want to see that night King show just
so I can know that it's gonna end the
most lackluster way for that kind same
way I was really rooting for a Boba Fett
Joe because I knew he would end in the
most lackluster way ever mister Katie
says mister Katie I loved that name what
is the Katie stand for let us know
is Kevin Camp this is how I imagined he
says it is Kevin Connor the best bevin
ever or what sure wow you know I can't
say it honestly I I cannot give it to
him Lee I know that's a controversial at
any time you choose a food reverb and
it's a controversial opinion but I can't
say that because he at the end of the
day he is only providing the voice and
it's kind of hard to say he's my
personal favorite when he's not doing
the physicality of the Bruce
wayne/batman portrayal which is very
important to embodying a performance you
know comes with it like he's got a great
voice actor and the most iconic voice I
would say but I can't say to the best
speak only because of that fact you know
like if taking Kevin Conroy step into
the Batsuit could he be Batman if he did
that and yeah there'll be something you
all need a mod to block spoilers yeah
well how do we do that that's a great
point that's a great point that's a
great point kick people out I'm thinking
I also by the way I also really am
rooting for the Snider cut to be
released by the way that's that's a big
I've been looking into those videos and
I support Zack Snyder I know you can
hear me baby girlfriend doesn't care for
the Snyder cut Jon Jon it can't be the
only one talking you just go quiet oh
sorry I'm trying to kick somebody out of
this chat and I don't know who are you
trying to kick out the person who keeps
spoiling spider-man who's the guy
spoiling spider-man I'm not gonna say
cuz then people are gonna go look and
get it spoiled and maybe if they don't
know they'll think that what they're
reading is not
and there may be not true ones in here
god dammit hey Matt Matt hey that's here
acting teacher said that my girlfriend
rules he just got a new a new client
that's how easy it is to get me to sign
up look at that
look Archy the guy loves you he wants to
know if you're seeing Trainspotting I
have Stran spot he's a great movie I
haven't seen the second Trainspotting
but I watched it on YouTube tea to
intervention day uh yeah no
transplanting is a great movie great
soundtrack great performances Danny
Boyle like old school like first time
around alright guys well we got a film a
reaction to we're starting up season 3
of Supernatural and we're gonna film
that right now trying to get ahead so we
can take fourth of July off hey look
since there's jerks here and we don't
know exactly how to block people yet off
of the livestream we're gonna fix that
next time if anyone's got advice for
kicking out people are like modding out
swirler yes okay here we go
were you guys small bill fans at all I
saw seasons 1 through 5 and I skipped
way ahead to the very final five minutes
of the show and that was a great 5
minutes Tom Welling was super game for
that and have you seen it yeah yes okay
oh look I know someone just said
something that I got to bring up Keanu
Reeves lately I've been living my life
by wkd Loba Keanu do and I think we all
should apply that mantra Jordan Gordon
low K a quick shout-out to everyone in
the super chat thank you to everyone
who's been here I gotta take initiative
and call it quits I've got to stay
strong we've only lost about 80 people
since I was hoping we will lose all one
huh 210 but some of you guys stuck here
thank you guys that dip damn I thought
we were I really wanted to keep it going
to ten come on oh now we're at I'm on
the 74 no we're supposed to be at ten
people watching Jon pull up the list of
people who did the super chat
we got Anthony Daly shouts out to you
Breanna Hanover shouts out to you Jordan
Gordon with the rhymes mr. mix spittle
whatever your save is comment and tell
me what that means and how to say it
mr. Katy a couple times in here Alfie
odd Henry I hope I'm not destroying your
name
and yeah it's that's who we got today
all right well thank you guys for being
here
thanks I appreciate everyone for chiming
in you could subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
don't forget to good time no alcohol
require get a Ridge wallet get stuck
mine eyes download Vikings war of clans
10 millions to start a stamp whoo